well the strip continues to evolve mgm
resorts announcing it's selling the
mirage to hard rock international for
one billion dollars kate houston spoke
to a long time mirage employee about how
this purchase could possibly impact jobs
i change sometimes is a good thing so
you know we welcome that change aaron
najera has worked at the mirage for 30
years and has gone through ownership
changes including when mgm resorts
acquired the property in 2000. right now
nobody's really worried because again
we've been through this and then you
know the first couple times we were
nervous
but not not anymore nahra says
historically these changes have not
impacted jobs nor benefits for those our
union we are you know at ease for now
you know we do
think about our brothers and sisters
that are not union
that hopefully there is no changes in
their employment in a letter to
employees mirage president nick
ritterstrom said there would not be
changes to jobs or daily operations from
now until the sale closes in mid-2022
mgm resorts will keep the mirage name
and brand licensing it to hard rock for
a few years as they finalize plans to
rebrand the property this rendering from
hard rock shows its plan to build a
guitar-shaped hotel next to the main
property it's unclear if this will take
over any current attractions including
the famous volcano nahara says they're
waiting to see what happens changes are
always good and so far the mirage has
always made good moves kate houston live
local now
as a part of the agreement the mirage
executive team is expected to transition
to hard rock they will hold a meeting
with hard rock reps to share more and
more information with employees and
answer any questions that might come up
[Music]